[Music]
we should the last two and a half days
going through all the submissions and
various other reports from the council
in relation to the long term plan which
of course looks about 10 years I think
the main things fairly clearly the new
stadium that we've ticked off for coal
stream Road Northern Europe it's a very
big project in the history of this
district but I think he quite clearly by
the submissions of something has
severely needed and very much wanted by
a large part of our community and while
we recognize that it's expensive it will
add a huge amount to sporting and
recreational fisherman industry for me
personally I think probably the most
important thing is a continuation of the
program and the red zones what alcohol
regeneration areas of of carboy and
particularly but also finds correctly
that's proceeding of course the new
roads are going in this we speak but all
on top of that most we develop sports
fields and other recreational things in
carboy that'll be really good to see
that happening over the next year and
following years and of course we've also
dealt with the question of refuse
collection the famous three bins if
discussion that's been going off years
and we seem to have consulted to death
we had to do it again this year because
there are rating implications and it
gives people a choice they can stay
exactly as they are if they wish very
close to what they are you can't avoid
the yellow top then but all the others
choices surround us and over the next
twelve months you'd expect to be asked
what you want to have for your
particular household it's a it's a
background of some challenge the
collapse of the mixed paper market in
China for recycling papers severely
impacting the whole country and we're
not a isolated in that so that's adding
a little bit to the rights of all refuse
collection because it's mainly about
recyclables so it's been a rewarding
exercise and I think we want to thank
everybody who's submitted it was very
helpful to us and the
and because we hit a large number of
submissions that makes the job easy in
many ways because we have a very clear
indication what the community wants
[Music]